hello guys welcome back to simply learn
youtube channel i'm sharmly and in
today's video we will discuss google ar
core also known as google play services
which is one of the leading software
development kits or sdks used to develop
ar based applications for both android
and cross platform machines
so without any delay let's get started
make sure to like this video and
subscribe to our youtube channel for
more interesting videos
do enable the bell icon to never miss an
update on any interesting topic
so
let's get started
reality technology is the hot talk of
the town today developing apps or
softwares plays a major role in
providing
reality experiences which is possible by
software development kit
sdks or integrated development
environment or ides
google ar core is one of the leading sdk
for developing ar apps which are simple
powerful and handy in providing app
development tools for both creators and
developers
so
as a part of today's video first we will
be discussing what is ar core
and then fundamentals of ar core
then we will look into the applications
followed by advantages and disadvantages
of er core
and at the end we will have a summarized
conclusion before starting with the
video let's have a brief introduction of
what is ar core
so google air core also known as google
play services is a software development
kit by google that allows developers to
deliver augmented reality experiences
via ar apps
in simple words ar core understands the
environment around you which helps to
provide interactive results on available
information
sdks provide a native application
programming interface or api with its
essential features like motion tracking
environmental understanding etc which
enables creating new ar experiences for
the user
now apis include or
i should say ar core by google is
composed of different apis
that help to develop
and
apps irrespective of operating system
they are off
so some common apis include android
studio android studio is an integrated
development environment or ide which
acts as a platform to build apps for
android phones tablets android wear etc
then comes unity
so as we know most of the trending and
adventurous games come under the name of
unity unity is a cross-platform game
engine which is used to develop video
games and simulations
next we have android ndk
ndk or native development kit is a set
of tools that allows programmers to use
c and c plus plus code with android
which provides pre-built libraries to
manage native activities and access
physical information of the system
and then we have unreal engine
unlike unity unreal engine is a game
engine by epic games where it was
initially developed for pc shooter games
now let's understand the fundamentals of
ar core
fundamentals of ar core include
first
motion tracking
so nowadays motion tracking is quite
common and a necessary feature in most
products like fitness apps
it allows your device to understand and
track its position in the real world
environment for better search reasons
next is environmental understanding
the basic function of developing an app
is to implement it on a real world
environment based on the factors of need
and functionality
this process helps
your device to detect the size and
location of the surface you are on
and at last we have
light estimation
lighting is the key factor of creating
realistic ar experiences this lighting
api analyzes the given images with its
detailed information on lightings in a
scene which helps to render virtual
objects
and interactions so as we have discussed
the key factors of fundamentals of ar
core
now let's move towards the applications
of arco
unlike ar and vr experiences ar core is
applicable in all fields like in terms
of entertainment and lifestyle
filters are quite common
nowadays and it's easily accessible via
social media which is possible only via
air effects
virtual shopping online shopping is the
current trend today the use of ar and
shopping enhances the feel and
experience of the user to the next level
by 360 degree
and perspective that looks the same as
the actual one
next we have education and training
so in recent days online education and
online training are quite popular due to
the key factors of accessibility which
eliminates the need of essential
resources
design and modeling for example a cd
engineer uses ar to create a model of
the physical objects as a hologram or 3d
models to provide a real-time scenario
of the simulated objects
next we have travel and tourism air
provides accurate information in terms
of distance location and available
services in a particular destination or
geographical area making travel easier
and more convenient
and then comes healthcare system which
is the most important
medical practitioners and surgeons use
ar for medical imaging disease analysis
etc
making it easy to provide better and
more accurate treatments avoiding direct
contact with patients or harmful
diseases
so far we have discussed
ar core its fundamentals and its
applications now let's discuss about the
advantages and disadvantages of google
ar core
to talk about
is its advantages ar core is simple and
works with common programming languages
like java and opengl whereas java is a
quite common and a popular programming
language known by most of us
it supports other development engines
and frameworks like unreal unity etc
which helps developers to develop ar
apps irrespective of the platform they
work on ar core needs no specific
prerequisites like it can be applied
even on existing devices which
eliminates creating
new apps for a particular device
and mainly ar code is a freeware and
needs no licensing or payments
now moving towards its disadvantages
ar core natively supports the android
system
then to use air features a minimum
version of android 7 is necessary
and third we have commonly available
features like body tracking is
unavailable in ar core so we have
reached the end of this video module
in this video we have discussed about
what ar core is the fundamentals of ar
core its applications and its advantages
and disadvantages
as the use of reality technology
increases it is important to develop ar
and vr based apps not only developing
apps but it is also important to manage
these applications for a sustainable
market stand
and for an easy process which avoids
additional cost and human resources to
develop new application for all needs
now this brings us to the end of this
video i hope you enjoyed this video and
learned something new from it thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here